okay so a nearer Targaryen is one of the
most tragic characters in The Song of
Ice and Fire originally promised the
kingdom she was contested and over time
ended up having to fight in the Civil
War just to gain back the thing that
should have been hers in the first place
renera has an incredible story attached
to her and throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking down exactly what
happens with her her fate was actually
spoiled by Joffrey during Game of
Thrones but unlike him we're gonna give
you a big warning before we proceed I'm
warning you we will be spoiling it all
in depth and this will ruin the series
without the way are you still with me
yeah thanks for clicking this now let's
get into a newer Targaryen foreign
if you watch Game of Thrones then you
might have seen raniera's fate was
actually spoiled by Joffrey oh [ __ ] here
he comes here here he comes
raniera Targaryen was murdered by her
brother or
brother his Dragon it ate her while her
son watched
what's left of us buried in the Crips
right down there what a stupid
anyway that's how it all ends but how
did we get there well renewa actually
started off as a very popular member of
the royal family chapter 12 of Fire and
Blood Chronicles her early life and one
of the first things we hear are called
is the realm's Delight born in 97 AC to
viserys and Emma if you had two brothers
but both sadly died shortly after being
born it was in 105 AC that she took to
Dragon riding and here she mounted
psyrax for the first time the book
Staten era was a very skilled writer
this year also came with some brutal
blows too her mother died during the
birth of her baby brother Balin and the
responsibility of the throne passed over
the hair in 105 AC she was announced the
heir and several of the houses swore
their allegiances to her the position of
air was of course taken away from her
Uncle Damon who was stripped of his
title due to making fun of Balin being
unable to replace him Damon really
believed for a time that he was meant to
rule and that the death of bailing could
even be a sign that the gods wouldn't
let anything get his way however renira
was chosen over him Andrew Damon
thinking fondly of the girl he didn't
really protest Damon ended up leaving
the kingdom and he traveled to
Dragonstone which is where he and
mazaria had a fling he also took the
dragon egg that was meant for baby Balin
and viserys ended up forbidding their
relationship due to him already being
married to Lady rear he sent envoys out
to tellity to break up and in the show
renero went along with them now after
Conquering the stepstones Damon returned
to the realm and he handed over his
newly appointed Kingdom of the narrow
sea to broker peace with his brother he
remained in King's Landing and it said
in the book that both rhaenyra and Damon
would stick out at night and that they'd
have sex in the brothels that line the
street of silk they were apparently
caught by Eric cargol and mushrooms
spread a lot of rumors of what they were
up to at the tournament of viserys's
Ascension renera had given her favor to
Kristen Cole and he was appointed as a
load protector she was head over heels
with him and mushrooms said that the
lessons from Damon were toured in the
hopes of seducing the night in the book
it said it was Holland and strong who
took a v card however the show switches
it up to be sir Kristen the rumors about
Damon doing it appear in both the book
and show though with this being a reason
that Damon is expelled from the kingdom
either way Alison ended up marrying
viserys and when she started popping out
babies the line of succession started to
become contested not only did Alison
have one melee she also had two however
to the surprise of many raniera was kept
as the heir unfortunately this would
create a fracture amongst the houses and
was at the wedding of renira and lanor
that things start to divide the series
doesn't go into this too much because it
presents the wedding as being the place
where Alison showed she was part of the
greens however the book stages The
Divide starting at the tournaments held
in celebration of the wedding the black
dragons could be seen snapping at the
greens and there became talk of there
being a party of the princess Kristen
dominate the tournaments and he killed
sir Joffrey during this and also broke
several of harwin's Bones though he
loved renira the marriage and rumors of
Damon slowly caused him to turn against
Renee rap and he ended up siding with
Alison becoming her royal protector
Harwin became runnier's and the pair
started to have an affair together they
had three sons under the guise of being
valerians and these were jaserys luceris
and also Joffrey bloody Joffrey now the
targaryens and valerians were both known
for their distinctive hair and with none
of the kids carrying this a lot of
rumors started spread we had the whole
eye slashing incident and when Alison
demanded punishment the Sarah shut
everything down he pretty much sided
with runira and to hammer home his
loyalty he made a treason to say that
they were strongs during this time Damon
had wet Elena Valerian but the pair
would end up having their relationship
come to a tragic end the show and looked
differ in their telling of the events
with a former having her go through the
childbirth that completely wiped her out
in the source material she knew she was
dying and wanted to fly Vega one more
time she went to climb the steps of the
tower but sadly she collapsed when doing
so however in the show she begs for
death fully aware that Damon doesn't
love her with all his heart Harwin and
Lionel were also killed at this point
when the pair perished at the fire in
harrenhal again the bug doesn't spell
out whether Alaris was behind it or not
and it leans into the curse with it
being blamed as the reason for their
deaths now this start off a year known
as the red spring in which several
characters died the first was Lane air
then Harwin and shortly after this we
got Leno before ending with viserys the
show does change things up with lanor
faking his own death whereas in the book
he was taken out completely by his
jealous lovers a call Damon raniero
marriages six months later in the book
and according to some of the sources she
was already pregnant before they wed the
pair left and went to drift Mark much to
the fury of viserys who hadn't approved
the wedding however they reconciled
shortly after in the book The Finger
slicing scene happened much later on the
timeline and basically how it was laid
out was that there was Raymond accusing
renira's kids of being Strong's which
then made her dispatch Damon he killed
the Lord and then and his cousins and
nephews fled to King's Landing he sat
before the king and basically broke down
mori's style about why the kids were
strongs but Sarah sat not along and
listened to their plea then out the blue
he announced that they'd be losing their
tongues nice they were cut out and when
viserys stood up he sliced his finger on
the throne viserys gained a fever after
this and maesters were powerless to stop
this spreading throughout his body
rhaenyra ended up bringing her own
maester in who advised they remove his
fingers and then the fever subsided and
he regained his hell now during this
Rooney had two other children in aegon
and beceros Damon was the daddy and They
Carried with them the classic Targaryen
hair the book says Alison took this as a
slide to her own son aegon and though
raniera denied this it definitely was
now one thing the show doesn't cover is
that raniera gained weight during her
five pregnancies and the whole stuff
with his Strong's also turned her very
better she was jealous over Allison
who'd managed to retain her figure
another show paints her out as the good
guy it's not really the case in the book
there's definitely Shades of Gray there
and she would snipe at Alison just as
much as Alison had sniped at hair I
think the show deliberately did things
differently so we could see some
character growth in her whereas in the
book she's definitely as Petty as the
rest of her family now though ranera
helped to save her father's life he died
shortly after and the dance of the
Dragons began in the show we see that on
his deathbed he accidentally tells
Allison about the prince who has
promised prophecy unfortunately wires
get crossed and others and things that
they're talking about their son this
never happened in the book and instead
Alison and Otto just decided to put
aegon on the throne in order to seize
power here Alison believes it's
viserys's Last Wish so pick your poison
on that one oh poison it now this
started off the dance of the dragons and
the book beautifully transitions from
eggen's Coronation into what she's up to
on Dragonstone melees never broke
through during it and instead cheers
rang out from King's Landing on dragons
still now there were screams of Agony
with rhaenya's third day of Labor taking
place learning about egg and being Crown
pushed her into labor and the book
describes it as the baby itself burning
with a fury desperate to get out the
process was horrifying for an ERA with a
cursing agon and Alison throughout she
also called the baby a monster and told
it to get out when the child came it was
sadly still born and malformed it's said
that it had a scaly short tail similar
to a dragon and Ranier about revenge to
her they'd taken her baby throne and
father and they were going to pay for it
the child was named visenya after one of
their gun's Sister Wives and its death
brought a major change in raniera a
funeral was held and she was crowned
with her own coronation the book says
that her first order was to Proclaim
Alison and agon Traders and she denied
the terms that they had offered her the
series had Otto arriving at Dragonstone
but in the book it just Grand maester
Orwell rainera asked him why he'd
betrayed her while Cyrax looked on and
they stripped him of his chains she
handed these to her own May stare and in
either terms which involved her being
Lady of Dragonstone all of her
supporters in King's Landing had either
switched sides of being killed and still
recovering from the birth she was at her
lowest point the greens had to drop on
them and had already sent out several
Ravens across the entire realm Renee did
the same thing and she used her sons to
drum up support with yasaris going to
Winterfell and also the Arie useris went
to Storm's end and Eamonn made lunch and
that's basically where season one ends
and after learning of Luke's death Damon
promised her a son for his son working
with mizoria assassins were sent into
the castle and these were called blood
and cheese they waited in Alison's
Chambers for Helena to bring the
children in to say goodnight and forced
her to choose which child would die she
said male or but they killed your Harris
instead and this sent her insane she had
the guilt of knowing that one of her
sons was dead and that the other knew
that they'd been chosen to die Elena
went insane and her kids were put in the
care of Allison now to get revenge again
called an aragogue girl and he went to
Dragonstone and the guise of being his
brother this was on a mission to kill
either raniera or a royal but he bumped
into his twin on the way up the pair
juked it out and you didn't know him
being able to tell them apart they
couldn't intervene they died in each
other's arms very sad and uh yeah it
just shows the whole Civil War thing and
brother Vs brother now the action made
the blacks really step things up and
Damon took over Harron Hall whilst
ranera commanded things from Dragonstone
they slowly started to recruit as many
Dragon Riders as they could as there
were several on the island that weren't
being used you see Dragonstone was
surrounded by villagers and it was said
that the targaryens from time to time
had frequented the pubs clubs a Magle of
strip throughout their reign they'd
sired many bastards and those showing
the peaches of the targaryens were
called in in order to ride dragons
alongside the blacks this brought both
Hugh hammer and also a character called
Nettles who I'll talk more about in just
a bit now it's during this time that
several battles Happened One involved
rhaenys against Damon Kristen Cole and
egg on II her Dragon May least an egg on
Sunfire met in the air before they
hurtled towards the ground When the
Smoke settled a blackened body believed
to be renesis was found and though aegon
was still alive he was critically
wounded he'd been burned so badly that
his armor had melted into his skin and
aegon was sent back to King's Landing in
order to recover during this time Eamonn
wore the crown and he sat on the Iron
Throne now the battle of the gullet then
happened and runira's first born
sanchiserus was killed during this
though the blacks won the bite his
Dragon flew too low to the Sea and it
was struck with artillery from the boats
Chase fell into the sea and though he
scrambled aboard some wreckage he was
shot by crossbows and the book says that
the death of lucera's broken near his
heart however it does say that in
jiserus is dead that she grew even more
hardened this made her into a sort of
warrior princess and if he'd seen her
then you'd know she was ready to kill
anyone that stood against her Damon took
over harrenhold during this time and
Eamon believed that he could strike him
down there he and Kristen mannered a
charge and this ended up taking six days
to get to the location however Damon got
rid of this early and it came from those
who were still loyal to him in King's
Landing as we saw in episode 1 the city
watch were fiercely loyal to him and he
helped the blacks to man an assault on
King's Landing when he returned and she
captured Alison who handed over the keys
and told her that the kingdom was now
hers when going to aegon's chamber
though they found them empty the king
had fled in order to escape the
execution renera almost instantly took
to the throne and she had people swear
to her throughout the day night what
about there were some bad Omens that
came from this and these were noticed
when she ended up getting off the throne
the Masters in attendance noted that her
legs and hands were mocked with Kurt's
Witcher Throne had given her through the
night this was seen as a rejection by it
and she ruled for only six months the
queen was initially welcomed though and
due to her popularity as a child King's
Landing loved her aegon was a pretty and
popular King due to the the rumors about
him and his exploits but she was seen as
someone who would help the realm into a
prosperous new period whether opinions
started to change over time and it just
got worse and worse for those that try
to switch from green to Black were seen
as hashtag fake friends because they'd
switch from black to Green in order to
save themselves granera said that false
friends are more dangerous than enemies
and she start to routinely have the
heads of the houses cut off that's like
a sort of head of the house and behead a
joke but moving on these heads were put
on spikes around King's Landing and to
make matters worse taxes started to
shoot up Thailand Lannister aka the
master of coin had basically moved a
large amount of the Kingdom's wealth
overseas and to locations that he could
control this left the blacks pretty poor
off and this renira instructed that the
taxes had to be raised everyone was made
to pay their Sharon King's Landing and
even Beggars were forced to hand out the
money things got so bad that people even
started to say there were taxes on the
rats inquisitors were sent out a round
of egg and support orders and the
freedom that people once had was
stripped away with them now having to
pay more for the privilege renero was a
nickname King maego with teats and this
ended up becoming something that people
would say for the next hundred years to
describe a cruel woman during this time
again's children were captured and
maylo's head was sent to her as a gift
his two accounts over what she did with
some saying she cried upon seeing this
whilst others said that she smirked the
head was cremated in Targaryen fashion
but all the death in dismay started
proving too much for an era obviously
the book doesn't have the dagger in it
but I can see this being where it's
injected into the show raniera was
supposed to be bringing the realm
together in order to make it ready for
the white walkers both your Harrison
viserys ruled with peace prominently on
their mind and knowing what we know this
is because they wanted everyone to be
United against the common threat I can't
see this being the case here too with
Ray thinking that she's basically let
her father down due to all the death
within the family a life of betrayal but
also sad because they become more and
more paranoid over time several people
were accused of being tried as to the
realm and this included coolest which
made his entire house and Fleet
abandoned her side now we've kind of
skipped over the character Nettles but
she became a prominent player during
this time it was rumored that her and
Damon were getting it on with the pair
apparently bathing together raniera
ordered her death but several people
thought this was a step too far and some
even switched sides to aegon after this
Damon was supposed to return home but
instead he went back to Harren Hall
which is where he had his final battle
against aemond Elena also ended her life
during this which enraged a lot of those
in King's Landing this was seen as being
caused by rhaenyra and some even
suspected that she'd had Helena murdered
whether this was true or not we don't
know but the point is that many believed
it and it showed how unpopular that
renura was this was known as the
storming of the Dragon pit and during it
Geoffrey was killed he tried to fly
Cyrax to defend his mother but the
dragon was pelted with stones and
Joffrey fell off his back and pedal
towards the ground the mob cut off the
limbs from his corpse stole his clothes
in jewels and they beheaded him showing
how much they hate the strong so sorry
targaryens now egg on the younger became
the heir at this point and Ranier and
her son fled King's Landing raniera had
to sell the crown in order to buy money
to stow away on a ship which would take
out a Dragonstone however she was
betrayed an aegon came back into the
story with his Dragon Sunfire as Joffrey
said runyo was eaten by the dragon
whilst her son watched on aegon ordered
that it was to be stricken from the
record that renero was ever Queen and
all the following Chronicles just
referred to as a princess really sad end
of the story man this dancer the dragons
wiped out many of the remaining ones and
it whittled down the targaryens after
decades and Decades of Peace targaryens
were almost brought to their knees by
themselves and raniera stands as a
horrifying example of that now that's
the character's life summed up is best
we could and I hope you enjoyed the
video obviously I loved hear your
thoughts on her and what you think they
might change for the show where any
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character you pick the comments out
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 10 which will be linked on the
screen right now yo are all Easter eggs
in it talk about how it ties in with the
buck and stuffy we're checking out if
you love the show as much as we do by
the way thank you for clicking the video
I've been poor I see you next time take
care peace